i will introduce suzanne first and then
um
rheem before you go i will introduce you
welcome to the dmice conference
this is the internship bonanza
two of my interns
interns that work with me this summer
are presenting so
i'll introduce them both i'm david door
and i
supervise the
care management plus team as well as i'm
the chief research information officer
here at oregon health and science
university
our first speaker is going to be suzanne
navarro
who we were
pleased to work with actually for a
second year
last year she
was
going into her senior year at jesuit and
this year she is going to be a freshman
at vanderbilt university
uh and she worked on our e-care plan app
last summer and then as well she worked
on another of our applications coach
she's interested in medicine and data
science
molecular and cellular biology and and
data science i i said medicine
so
suzanne do you want to get started
yeah thank you dr dore for the
introduction um so i just wanted to let
you guys all know um
first of all good morning and i'm
probably gonna need to shut off my video
just because um i'm actually in
nashville right now and
the wi-fi isn't super good where i'm at
so just so you know
i will get sharing in just a second
um could someone let me know if they can
see my screen
it looks great i can see it
perfect thank you lynn
so good morning everyone my name is
suzanne navarro and as dr doris said i'm
a rising freshman at vanderbilt
but i'm from portland oregon and today
i'm going to be presenting on the
research projects that i worked on this
past summer the ecare plan app for
patients with multiple chronic
conditions
and
coach
so this is kind of going to be the
layout for my presentation today
so um i'm going to start off with e-care
plan background and then what i did last
summer and then this summer and then
just a little bit about coach
[Music]
so almost one in three adults in america
are currently affected by multiple
chronic conditions or mccs for short
mccs disproportionately affect women
racial and ethnic minorities and
low-income individuals
patients with multiple conditions
usually see multiple providers to help
with each of their conditions as we know
and a lack of care coordination amongst
the patient's providers all too
frequently results in wasted time and
money
this is supported by the purple portions
of figure 13 which shows that people
with chronic conditions make up for a
disproportionate amount of health care
spending
and lack of care coordination most
importantly results in lower quality
care and worse patient health outcomes
as evidenced by the disproportionately
larger readmittance rate for mcc
patients in figure 14.
so ehr or electronic health records
systems such as epic and mychart have
become widely implemented in recent
years in various healthcare settings
and while existing health it or health
information technology interventions
like ehr systems have greatly improved
care coordination among providers
and have greatly improved the clarity
and accessibility of medical data for
non-mcc patients
they have had limited success improving
mcc patient care
so the goal of the project is to improve
the quality of care for mcc patients
particularly those with chronic kidney
disease or ckd
by tailoring health i.t to their unique
needs
the proposed solution for reaching this
goal was to build the ecare app an app
which will work in ex in existing ehr
workflows serves as a tool for both
providers and patients that contains the
patient's comprehensive care plan and
all of their medical information in one
place
enhances patient understanding of their
medical data and emphasizes patient
goals to providers
so there were many collaborating
institutions involved in this project
on the left there is a summary of the
collaborators and their roles
fire
or fast healthcare interoperability
resources was also integral to this
project as it standardizes data formats
and interactions so that ehr code can be
used on a variety of platforms without
having to be rewritten
fire is part of what makes this project
innovative populating the ecare app with
data from epic
the bottom right picture shows the fire
workflow
and so i'm going to begin by going into
some of the stuff from last summer
so um first both provider and patient
facing versions of the ecare plan app
were built
so this is the health status evaluation
and outcomes page of the app in the
provider facing app on the left and then
on your right is going to be the
corresponding page in the patient facing
app
and
so there was a lot of preparation that
had to be done for usability testing of
the app once it was created
so this included designing a simulation
patient dubbed patricia noel to be the
archetypal patient that would have this
app as part of her care
she has mcc advanced ckd and multiple
care teams across healthcare settings
the team created three different medical
scenarios
that kind of followed like a progression
in her care in order to test all aspects
of the app
in addition because of her set medical
conditions and medical data when she
is used to test the app the team
can immediately know if the e-care plan
isn't displaying everything that it
should
and so here's a screenshot of patricia's
scenarios on this slide complete with
medications referrals and more
and
a user acceptance testing form was
created as well to guide usability
testing
as it contains all the questions that
facilitators for usability testing ask
participants in order to get their
feedback so
usability testing was pretty much done
um
in ohsu so
it wasn't sourced out to other
collaborators
and um so the uat questions were crafted
with the intent of making uat as
structured and efficient as possible
so here is a screenshot of a portion of
the form
and so for collecting data or collecting
provider and patient feedback um during
usability testing um i made a data
collection form and smartsheet and it
made collecting and interpreting the
feedback extremely efficient
and here's a little picture of a portion
of it
and one more thing that was done as
preparation for usability testing was
making training materials for those
learning to use the app
so this included tip sheets training
sessions and training slides
so on the top um there's going to be on
the top of the slide there's going to be
a picture of part of a tip sheet and
there's some guiding instructions and
arrows on it with pictures of the app
and below it is going to be a training
slide from the deck used in training
sessions that
essentially tells providers what to
expect during uat
and uatu was conducted
and involved getting provider feedback
over the course of an hour on matters
such as functionality usability and how
helpful the app would be for patient
care
uat helps us see how easy the app is to
use for those who don't have as much
experience with it as well as how
helpful the app would be for patients
with mcc
this usability testing was conducted in
the app's test and live environments
so the providing the provider-facing
test and live environments um can be
accessed through epic poc
and epic prod or production respectively
and the patient-facing test environment
is accessed through my chart poc
both test environments are populated
with patricia noel's medical data while
epic production contains real patient
data
and the real patients whose data was
chosen for usability testing
had to meet certain inclusion criteria
so preferably that they were
like the participating providers patient
so that the provider could tell us if
something wasn't showing up on the app
that should have been
and that they had mcc
at least one of which was ckd
and
so here are some pictures of the
provider facing app
and this is the care team
section
and findings so the app was found by
participating providers to be very
intuitive to navigate and to use they
thought it would allow for more
efficient and effective reviews of
patient data and goals before visits
and particularly
they pointed out the diagnoses labs and
vitals and goals focus areas as their
favorites and most useful
in doing this
and overall providers agreed that the
app would add substantial value to
patient care
however last summer we found there were
a few problems within the app
so additional labs weren't showing for
patients with more medical data than the
app was used to
um and medications were slow to load for
some of the patients with more data
and goals were also usually missing from
live patients and furthermore um
a lot of the
well a sizable amount of the providers
said that they wish they could have like
um they could see comments from other
providers in order to get additional
details that were not already recorded
in the app
so um
for instance if like patients were
forgetting to take their medications
that would be something that they would
want to know about in the app
and so these are the pages um that they
particularly liked as i um referenced
before
um
and so the providers specifically liked
pages one and four because of their com
consolidation of key data while still
keeping that necessary specificity that
we want
um
in you know managing someone's health
care
and
they also thought that the goals section
under page 2 was very helpful and
innovative because that's not something
that you would see in other ehr systems
like epic
and resulting changes so based on the
first round of uat some changes were
made
the hour-long blocks of time for uat
were shortened to 30 minutes for the
sake of efficiency
and the uat and smartsheet forms were
shortened accordingly
also
a video walkthrough of the app to
account for app down times was created
and the additional labs issue
for live patients is now was fixed
pretty shortly after
the rounds of usability testing
and um this took
going through the apps logs
in order to track down where the errors
were occurring and
what exactly they were
and testing in epic poc and production
to ensure that things had been properly
fixed
and
so this little portion of an excel
spreadsheet is
um kind of something i put together last
summer
um where
inconsistencies between the app and epic
um
were compiled um
and there was also like a word document
with screenshots and notes on these
problems
um that helped with debugging the app
and a lot of the problems that were
found relating to data missing
from the app were due to problems with
fire rather than the app
as fire is still
a relatively new tool
and so yeah um
this is pretty much just a portion of
that excel spreadsheet minus the medical
record numbers of course
and
since summer of 21
so
we had done a bunch of provider testing
just like i
said um but now we had patients trying
out the ecare plan app
so we had initially planned to have
providers that had been already selected
and had accepted to be part of the
project to train patients on how to use
the patient-facing app
but it ended up being our usability
testing facilitator that helped train
them and then conducted uat with them
and so the most
they most commonly reported that the
patient app wasn't sufficiently
different from the my chart
um that they already used
so the basically the provider facing
application was pretty good just a few
little bugs to be fixed
but it was like new and it was extra
helpful
but the patient-facing apps still needed
some work
summer 22
so um i'm going to get into
um
what like
what we've been doing with the
patient-facing app in a sec
but
this summer
um
involved
me working on like the usability methods
paper um with rti so i wrote some
background paragraphs on um a few
usability
tools
and
in ecare plan we had primarily been
using
the system usability scale but
um so in this paper we were trying to
branch out and see what other things
there were and how useful that would be
to ecare plan
so i first started out with researching
health it usability evaluation model or
health it uem
and then the system usability scale
and nielsen's usability heuristics
and i read through many study abstracts
in order to compare these testing tools
and including these comparisons in these
background paragraphs
and so this will probably become a joint
rti and ohsu blog post about the ecare
plan usability testing
so just a little bit of background
um for those of you who may not know um
a ton about these tools because some of
them are relatively new
um the health ituem was developed as a
combination of multiple usability models
in order to address the gaps in
implementing the individual models
so the nine components of health ituem
are air prevention completeness
memorability information needs
flexibility and customizability
learnability performance speed
competency and a catch-all of other
outcomes
and the system usability scale is
essentially a 10-point questionnaire
that is answered by test participants
in order to gauge the app's usability
each question has five answer options
ranging from strongly agree to strongly
disagree
and these qualitative answers can be
converted into quantitative scores out
of one hundred
um which just makes them a little bit
easier to parse and especially when
comparing studies it's a lot easier to
see
um
to compare like the efficacy of certain
apps and stuff
and nielsen's usability heuristics a
usability testing framework that
is not specific to healthcare
consists of 10 components for
assessing the usability of a given
digital interface
and these are the ten
so i will just give you all a moment to
read through them
and so basically um
some of this research was done just to
see a little bit more about what's out
there and compared to what we did on
e-care plan with the system usability
scale
and we might possibly consider using a
blend of more than just system usability
scale for usability testing
done in version 2.0 of the ecare plan
app
which is just about starting
pretty much this week actually
and so here's some initial comparisons
between the tools as shown in same
colored highlights
and then using this i was able to
create a few paragraphs comparing and
contrasting
the tools
and reading some articles about software
quality and testing also helped me with
writing these paragraphs so that was
super useful and i'm
very glad that was included as part of
the internship through michelle
and i also helped make a graph to count
the number of notes patients had at hsu
and other big health providers in the
area
in the portland metro area
in order to find the average number of
notes from ohsu the percentage of nodes
from ohsu and the percentage of notes
from
other providers and going through the
patient notes also helps determine which
patients may be good candidates for the
ecare plan app so with um version 2.0
starting just about now um that could be
very useful
and ecare plan version 2.0
um so like i said it is pretty centered
on changing the patient app based on
input from last summer's usability
testing and this process is pretty much
just kicking off this week
and
as promised just a little bit about
coach
so i tested the coach app um which was
pretty similar to testing the e-care
plan app so i was able to use a lot of
the skills that i learned last year and
continued improving this year um
in coach which was great
and this testing involved using real
patients and a testing framework that
michelle one of the team members on the
e-care plan app created
and a super brief background on coach
it's a clinical decision support tool
for people with high blood pressure
and
just a little update on how coach is
going so
after the testing we were able to
determine that everything is working
pretty well
and the average response time for
recommendations so recommendations
are basically like
what the system gives you as a patient
based on your high blood pressure
readings and your medications
and so these recommendations the
response time
was decreasing overall with the patients
that were tested so i think there were
about 20 patients that were tested
um
and the only real issue that we found is
that two patients had a hypertension
diagnosis and epic but in coach the
recommendations were saying that they
didn't have a diagnosis um so that it
was great that um
the recommendations were telling us that
they didn't have that
so that we knew that something wasn't
working properly
um
but this was found to be a problem with
cqf ruler
um i could not do it justice if i tried
to explain what cqf ruler is but
basically it's something that um
has to work with the app and so it ended
up just being like
a problem with a newer version of the
app and so
um that we were using at the time that
we were testing these two problematic um
patients
um
and so
more functional versions of the app have
in that they work better with cqf ruler
have been made since
and so here is a snapshot of the home
page of the app
and of the framework questions that were
part of like a longer
excel spreadsheet
and here are a few citations um
from the figures that i had earlier and
a little bit on health i.t and then
disability tools that i had to research
and
so as i conclude my presentation i would
like to give a special special thanks to
dr dore to michelle the rest of the
ecare and cmp teams
and to d mice for um all helping make
this internship experience what it was
and i think this concludes my
presentation for today um
are there any questions
yeah we've got a little bit
of time for questions thank you suzanne
it was a delight to have you
albeit very virtually this year
thank you dr dory
it was great being on the team again
anybody have any questions you can type
into the chat or
just speak up
okay well
maybe we'll go on to the next
presentation thanks again suzanne it was
uh
really enjoyed hearing the overview of
usability testing and
the improvements that you made will be
used um for the next versions so thanks
again
um now i'm it's my pleasure to
introduce rheem saleh
[Music]
who was our other
one of our three interns actually this
year
rheem are you on
there she is
uh so
rheem
uh recently oops
i had your intro already sorry
recently graduated from the honors
program um
at portland state university
with a bs in data science
minor in math and is
interested in going on to a master's in
data science so very passionate about
data science within health care
she worked with us on
a project that
due to the government's being very slow
really
didn't fully get started it was uh our
bridge to ai project um which she will
talk about and tell you about but we
were very grateful to have her to sort
of think through uh how we might get
started and
some of the major issues so um i i think
it was such a pleasure and and she did
attend virtually again the aim ahead
um
uh projects uh first series of webinars
which is focus on uh inequity you know
basically making ai more equitable and
uh
so um i will leave it to you
thank you for the introduction dr dore
i'm gonna try
and get my screen shared
hopefully you guys can see like my
presentation title
looks great i can see it okay sounds
good thank you
okay so yeah thank you for the
introduction um
so yeah my name is rinsha i'm one of the
interns for the d mice department um
working under dr door
my presentation today will be about
artificial intelligence biases and trust
within healthcare
so just an overview real quick just a
little bit about what i'm going to be um
talking about i'm going to give a rough
background
on ai and then the bridge to ai project
um what is ai specifically the purpose
of even looking at like the issues
within ai the biases and the purpose of
having the bridge tie project
the mission of bridge to ai and then
something i worked on and then finally
key takeaways from the internship and
then just from all of the things that i
did research on and learned throughout
the internship
so a little bit about me kind of uh dr
dora already mentioned this i'm a recent
grad of the psu's honors college with
the bs in data science minor in math
continuing to pursue master's in data
science and then coming into this
internship i had experience coding in r
python and sql which
i gained throughout my two years at
portland state
so
like dr door mentioned the project i was
initially brought on for was the bridged
artificial intelligence project the
bridge to ai project
which specifically with ohsu we would be
working on the educational and outreach
aspect of working with ai in healthcare
however this project's funding kept
getting pushed by pushed back and i
wasn't able to contribute as much as was
expected
but although that happened i was able to
focus on the biases that arise when
working with ai and attended a symposium
and some workshops to learn more about
these
these concerns
along with this i was able to help
work on writing an abstract
for the pacific symposium on
biocomputing too
which will also be focused on more on
the ethical aspects which we're working
on with other people
for the bridged ai program
so let me just say a little bit about
the reason i had even joined this
project in the first place is because ai
is such a fascinating tool that can be
used to our advantage and it has so many
applications to it it's continuously
growing and has so much potential to
help with different fields but
especially within healthcare but when we
work with this type of technology and
the data that comes with working with it
it's important to be aware and consider
the issues that can arise and a huge
part of these issues are the biases that
can come when working with ai and then
also
trying to get trust with people is hard
especially because of the way ai is has
been depicted in movies over the years
as these sort of scary robots that can
take over if we let them or um can
somehow
take over its algorithms and coding and
and whatnot and
kind of run around on its own
so these are all just things to consider
when working with ai and especially when
applying it in a healthcare setting
where there's other people's information
being utilized and it's important to
protect what is given to us safely
so i want to start by actually defining
what ai is so that we're all on the same
page and have a stronger understanding
of what it actually is
it's a term we've probably been hearing
a lot about and i personally have been
hearing it more and more in the field of
data science and all of its applications
and oh wow how much it can do
a formal definition from oracle is that
it's systems or machines that mimic
human intelligence to perform tasks and
can iteratively improve themselves based
on the information they collect
so essentially we're building these
systems that are able to make
conclusions on their own based off of
information that we provide for them so
it's stuff we give to them and this said
there's different types of artificial
intelligence like neural networks
robotics machine learning and a couple
more
machine learning is specifically what
bridge to ai would will be utilizing to
help aid in decisions health care
providers make in their work because of
its like massive computational abilities
specifically with voice data which i'll
be getting a little more into
um there's also so many different
applications like um within social media
education healthcare robotics finance
automobiles agriculture and so so much
more those are just a couple i've listed
um specifically with the bridge to ai
the it'll be focusing on voice data and
potentially it can help um determine
what type of disorder someone may have
based off of their voice data that we
collect
so for example we can have
voice data from patients that have
disorders and those that oh that don't
have disorders to aid in this process so
more specifically our voice has many
different components to it and we can
look at the
waveform waveforms our voice produces
and the different components that create
sound and see if there's any irregular
irregularities that occur and certain
people with disorders and then compare
it to people without to
help aid in this process so
however this can requires a lot of time
and thought put into it even to ensure
that the model can even be reliable and
another thing to consider when working
with healthcare and patient information
is the biases that arise when working
with this type of technology
so what even is bias there's
there's a lot of definitions out there
going around but there's these two main
aspects that i want to kind of highlight
and think of on a very broad scale this
is there's two different ones this is
the statistical concept which are
essentially the systematic errors that
the model actually makes but then
there's also the social and ethical
concepts um which i have uh which are
the prejudices that is prevalent in
society today so i did mention a little
bit about the biases that can arise when
we create a model
and this may be because of the data that
the model
um
is used is using itself can be biased
and skewed to a certain category so for
example let's say we have more data on
people from european descent than those
of african latino or latina or asian
descent and it's not balanced um towards
the entire population it's it's viewed
towards the european
so from this stage the model may be
biased and make inaccurate decisions for
someone who is asian because there's
only data accurate data and enough data
for europeans
however biases don't only arise in the
data and the stuff that's put into the
model but also when we're creating the
model when we're collecting the data and
implementing the model everyone has
their own subtle biases ingrained into
that they're raised with
and it's pretty much impossible to
remove them from someone but having a
diverse group of example people coding
can be one method to help reduce this
so let's say another example towards
this aspect is let's say you're hiring
people to help develop a certain model
for your project
you have this mindset that maybe people
that come from prestigious schools or
hold phds are the only ones or that are
the ones that are best qualified for
this however you're showing
prejudice against others and overlooking
everyone else that may have more
redeeming qualities and experiences but
based off of your experience and beliefs
you're not providing an open mindset to
everyone so as you can see there's so
many different ways of wait how bias can
occur and this can be talked about for
hours
but now that i've kind of touched on it
and given some examples on where my
peers or how it can appear i want to
move on to more of the purpose of this
project and the purpose of even thinking
about this when working with ai
so
the purpose of not only using voice with
ai but data from different topics to ai
is because it has so much potential as
we can see our voice here from an
article we can see your voice can help
uh reveal if we have heart problems it
can serve as a a biomarker again our
voice specifically to the bridge
of a.i
project but there's also um other ways
it can aid within healthcare and outside
of healthcare for example copit19 very
important um
drugs digital manufacturing forecasting
human diseases
or even predicting the progression of
diseases however with these amazing
articles and headlines that we see from
universities and hospitals using ai more
and more towards their advantage there
are downsides and articles that show the
other side of it
for example in an article published by
harvard business review we see the
shocking title of why ai failed to live
up to its potential during the pandemic
so this article has four main things
that it talks about that caused this
fail it mentions
it's bad data sets automatic
discrimination human error and complex
and uneven global context so these are
all important things to consider when
working with ai and again we see more
articles like this biases and ai within
healthcare
more biases and even more biases it's
always one of the top reasons that a
model is not as accurate as we hope now
that i've given like some more real-life
examples to show how to show the
research and thought that's being put
into this issue and how it's being
thought about with the bridge to ai
project i want us to pull back into
bridge to ai specifically and its
mission overall across the u.s and
osha's use ohsu's specific side to it
so the main mission there's a couple of
um main goals of the project but these
are the main ones that kind of pull from
slides and content that we have
it's essentially to create ethical and
trustworthy data sets that are easily
accessible to users
but also not only easily accessible but
also develop guidelines around voice ai
research including data sharing privacy
ownership etc to help facilitate data
access and delivery in a secure manner
that leaves all users safe and protected
so it's our mission to provide easily
accessible data but make sure it's safe
along with this more on the ohsu side
where it's our mission to provide
resources and training materials to
healthcare providers and people who will
be using this data to help understand
the importance of having fair and
ethical data sets
so overall our goal is to provide these
data sets to help in future research and
research and implementation of ai within
healthcare
but also setting guidelines and creating
materials that guide and safe and
in safe and protected work
so because the mission of bridged ai as
a whole is to provide data to people
openly and securely an aspect of it is
education and outreach to the people
that will be
utilizing the data working with ai and
then also the patients too that will be
giving away their data to people to use
so like i mentioned since ohsu side to
it is education outreach to
everyone that will be involved in this
project is um a aspect to this that i
worked on with christy jackson is a
video consent where we our
goal is to create a video that will help
educate and inform people patients and
potential patient patients so we created
an outline and highlighted main points
that we would think would be important
for a video consent but then also
help
kind of alleviate people's fears and
reduce some of the skepticism people
have so
having this um in an easier and
understandable form for patients and
potential patients um can help
kind of guide them and serve as a bridge
to ensure that they're not as fearful
but we're also reaching out to different
communities to educate them and outreach
is a big aspect outreach so what's
actually going to be in this video some
of the key points that we want to
highlight are to make sure that we let
the viewers know the risk of
participating in this research
and not keep it hidden how their data
will actually be used how it'll be kept
private safe and secure and then also
let them know about all the help and
benefits that their data will be able to
aid with research and different projects
so this is just an example of one of the
education materials that ohsu will work
on to create and implement with um to
help with the collection of data for the
bridge to ai project and this leads me
to my final key takeaways
for
the entire internship as a whole but
then also
the project and then when thinking about
working within ai and
just data science in general um the
three main things i've learned is
awareness education and outreach these
seem kind of cliche but they're also
really important when working with
healthcare data
to help potentially reduce bias reduce
the fear and help be inclusive with this
technology from start to finish
so although i wasn't able to be as
hands-on and work on the project i was
brought on for due to reasons that were
outside of our control i was definitely
able to learn a lot about the risks that
come with working with ai that many
developers overlook and understand the
different aspects to it and different
steps that can be taken to help reduce
the amount of biases that come when
working with ai so being even aware like
listening to this presentation you're
aware of these biases that can arise
that you may have and are outside of
your control but
having the sense of awareness that this
can arise and that there are ways to
help
reduce the amount of bias there is is
the first step in the right direction
and then continuing to educate and um
reach out to people is also really
crucial and not just assuming that
everyone knows that there's biases and
that we just have to deal with them but
also
understanding that there are ways to
help reduce the amount of bias that is
present in a model
um and just to be um aware again
awareness is a huge thing about the
biases that can arise
so this leads me to my end of my
presentation i want to say thank you
specifically to dr david dorr mj dunn
chrissy jackson
jackson and the rest of the cmp team
thank you guys
thank you rheem
uh questions for rheem
clapping
yay
well rheem we've really enjoyed having
you oh
kate you have a question yeah i have a
question reem and actually um suzanne
you did a fabulous job um reim i was
wondering in your work with ai did you
are looking at it and looking at biases
was there's particular
um
situations that you would like to like
problems that you would like to
go ahead and do some more research on um
particularly like
um ai for the patient or ai
for the researcher was there something
in what you saw that you would like to
work more on
um i think something that would
definitely be super interesting to look
more into is kind of um how people
handle
um
when they have biases and data and how
can they even like flag it down let's
say for example you can you see the
example i gave with the european descent
being more prominent how
because you know it takes a lot of money
and effort to even gather that data in
the first place
i
it would be definitely super interesting
to help aid in the process from the
beginning to ensure that you know that
we're thinking about all aspects we're
not just trying to think of this certain
community but also this community we
want to kind of be as inclusive as
possible
so because it's you know caught it's
cost so much and it takes a lot of
effort to even get that data in the
first place
it would definitely be interesting to do
more research on the before that even
happens to help reduce that as much as
possible from like i said hiring
different backgrounds um people from
different backgrounds because you know
we all have different mindsets and we
think differently
so
having a diverse group in the first
place that's working on it is kind of
one step in the right direction because
you all bounce ideas off of each other
we have different opposing ideas but
we're kind of getting as much as we can
within that group in the first place
so yeah no i think that's that's one way
to look at it too because there's not
enough diversity on on what people are
who people are helping with and stuff
like that to do
the research on that but that sounds
great so
again thank you for your presentation
awesome thank you for your question
hey reem this is aaron cohen i have a
comment more than a question
um
is that okay
no worries go ahead
yeah well i mean i think i think what
you're talking about is is really
important and there's you know a bit of
a
divide between the people that are
building these models and the people
that are maybe
you know
identifying and characterizing these
issues i think there's really room for
you know sort of best practice guidance
in this field like
both
when you're
designing a project to build these
models but also
you know after you've built the model
with the limitations and making it clear
what those limitations are and who they
apply to and
you know so i i think there's a lot of
room if you're interested for sort of
teasing out and
you know describing in some you know
published and easily followable
referenced way best practices for
[Music]
the construction and application of
machine learning and ai models in
in in medicine and health care i mean i
i i do a little of of what you're
talking about now as i've been come
aware of it um like just for example
just you know looking at uh
um
you know
looking at how well calibrated the
models are in in in different subsets of
people with different groups and stuff
like that and you know especially at
ohsu when we're using oh you do you data
there's just groups that are so far
underrepresented that the model really
shouldn't be used on those groups of
people and and shouldn't um
it doesn't really have anything useful
to say on groups of people other than
who it was trained on and that has to be
one of the big sort of published caveats
and limitations of the model one would
hope that that would then spur
other people
or
you know to build similarly useful
models with appropriate data for other
groups of people or
you know and i know that n3c has tried
to go in this direction you know
assemble data that is more
representative so that you can actually
build models um on uh that are
you know useful and relevant and not
misleading to other uh wider groups of
people but i i think as long as we're um
dealing with localized data sources
we're probably going to have to
admit our limitations that the models
that we're building really apply to
populations that look like that
population and not and not others and i
suppose the best you can do and this is
where best practices will come off but
you know from my experience the best
that i know how to do is just to study
that and point it out is like you know
the calibration of this model on you
know non-white people is just
not good and not useful and shouldn't be
applied to that and there needs to be
you know future work that incorporates a
greater diversity of of of data and and
people in this
you know whatever the whatever the
particular ai question is
yeah thanks for your comment i
definitely agree see like you mentioned
the word away or you're aware that's
kind of one of the things i focused on
and
definitely with like you mentioned like
having these standards and it's
definitely hard to have but it would be
great if we could have those but it's
hard to get everyone you know on board
everyone has these mindsets but like
also you like you said when you have
these models that are calibrated to
um like you look at their calibration
and whatnot it's like even mentioned
some people don't even mention that
it's skewed but if you mention that like
it's geared towards this population that
i mean that's fine because you're not
using that
against a different population that's
not for that model
that makes any sense so
it does i'll say it is a certain kind of
bias that you know we're doing this work
and creating this model and it's really
only helpful for certain groups of
people because of our data limitations
and it would be better
if
you know that led to
broader models or repeated work that
would cover broader sets of people it's
not really a good
end point to have
the best models you have are sort of
biased and limited and you can only use
them on these people and not on others
so i think that you know some way of
continuing to to
to point out that it it's it's it's like
in my mind it's acceptable to point out
the limitations but that shouldn't be
the permanent end state
oh yeah definitely not we want to be
able you know because in healthcare we
want to help our entire population and
especially those that come from a
minority background because they are the
ones that have been underrepresented so
i think um hopefully in the next couple
of years
we're like talking about this right now
like i'm aware of it um i entered attend
the symposium the entire symposium was
about health equity so just kind of um
just stepping in this in this direction
and um just talking about it
continuously talking about it who knows
maybe in the future
i'll dive more deeper into this and
create some publication it's definitely
something i'm passionate about
especially within the field of data
science especially because ai is growing
and it's becoming more and more powerful
so that's that's something i'm i'm
hoping to pursue yeah
right
right well this was a great series of
presentations thank you not that i'm
biased but uh and appreciate the
interaction uh susanna reim we wish you
the very best do stay in touch we will
be thinking about you and uh
hopefully we'll be able to uh hear great
things from you in the future
uh lynn are we on for next week um yes
okay great is there more yeah second
date yeah there'll be a second day i'll
get the announcements announcement out
um today
great so uh look forward to more intern
presentations next week all right take
care everybody
thank you